نسالك نجوان وانت في غلاف غزه في متابعه
للتطورات الميدانيه وكذلك ما يخرج من
الجيش الاسرائيلي حول ما قال انها نتائج
تحقيق اولي حول مقتل الاسرى الثلاثه ماذا
في التفاصيل
نجوان نعم هذا البيان الذي صدر قبل قليل
عن المتحدث العسكري الاسرائيلي لما يقول
بانه تحقيق اولي فقط وان التحقيق
مازالت جاريه في ملابسات ما حدث يوم امس
تحديدا عند الساعه العاشره صباحا في حي
الشجاعيه ابرز ما ما تطرق اليه هذا
الاعلان قبل قليل عن التحقيقات الاوليه
يشير الى نقطتين اذا قصف مدفعي عنيف الان
ايضا على المناطق الشرقيه في منطقه غزه من
وراء حي
الشجاعيه وحي الزيتون ونرى هذا القصف المت
م واصل ايضا على هذه المناطق كنا قد رصدنا
معكم صباح هذا اليوم القصف المتواصل على
المناطق الشماليه في مناطق بيت لاهيه وبيت
حنون والان هذا القصف المتواصل ايضا على
مناطق شرق قطاع غزه سواء كان القصف
المدفعي وايضا غارات يشنها سلاح الجو
الاسرائيلي على مواقع مختلفه في هذه
المناطق لكن اعود الى البيان الذي اصدره
الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي قبل اي قليل
ويتحدث عن تحقيقات اوليه تظهر بان ثلاثه
المحتجزين الاسرائيليين خرجوا من احد
المباني في حي الشجاعيه وكانوا يلوحون
باعلام او بخرق بيضاء وفقا لما قاله ورغم
ذلك رغم ان هناك اوامر في الجيش
الاسرائيلي وفقا لهذا البيان بعدم اطلاق
النار على اشخاص يلوحون بالاعلام ال يضاء
الا انه تم استهداف هذه المجموعه والتي
اتضح لاحقا بانها ثلاثه من المحتجزين
الاسرائيليين تم استهدافهم فقتل على الفور
قصف
مجددا قتل على الفور اثنان منهم مباشره تم
رصد قتل اثنين من المحتجزين فيما عاد
احدهم الى المبنى الذي خرجوا منه فيبدا
و بدا كان احدهم ايضا يتحدث باللغه
العبريه ويقول ه تسيلو باللغه العبريه
بمعنى انقذونا لكن مع ذلك ظن الجيش او
القوات المتواجده هناك وفقا لهذا البيان
بانهم يحاولون بانهم مسلحين او مقاومين
فلسطينيين يحاولون استدراج هذه القوه الى
داخل المبنى وبحسب ايضا البيان فان
القائد للكتيبه التي تواجدت على الارض
اصدر اوامر بعدم اطلاق النار على الشخص
الثالث الا انه بمجرد ان خرج مجددا من
المبنى تم استهدافه وقتله هو الاخر
وبالتالي بحسب البيان هناك مخالفه لقواعد
فتح اطلاق النار على هذه المجموعه تكرر
عده مرات عمليا تكرر عندما تم استهداف
اشخاص يرفعون العلم الابيض وثانيا ايضا
عندما صدرت اوامر من قائد الكتيبه بعدم
اطلاق النار على الشخص الثالث خالف احد
الجنود ذلك
وا قتله لكن يعني في بيان الجيش يتطرق الى
نقاط اخرى يتحدث فيها عن انه حدث في
السابق تحديدا في حي الشجاعيه ان تم
استدراج قوات لكن بهذه الطريقه لكن بكل
الاحوال مريم بالاضافه الى حاله الارباك
وكنا قد ايضا ت عاملنا مع الخبر الذي نشر
قبل ايام قليله في وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه
بانه منذ بدايه هذا
القتال قتل ما لا يقل عن 20 جنديا في هذه
المعارك بنيران توصف بالصديقه بمعنى انها
تبادل لاطلاق النار بين الجنود لكنها لا
تعبر فقط عن حاله ارباك وانما تعبر عن
حاله من تعمد استهداف حتى من يظن الجيش
ويعتقد بانهم من المدنيين بمعنى انه من
رفع الاعلام ال البيضاء اي وايضا حاولوا
الخروج من هذا المبنى يعني ما كان الجيش
ليتعامل مع كل هذا الموضوع ومع كل هذه
القضيه وما كان ليصدر بيان بانهم قتلوا عن
طريق الخطا لولا انهم اتضح محتجزين بمعنى
ان هذا الوضع المتكرر منذ بدايه هذه الحرب
واستهداف المدنيين بشكل مباشر لا يتم
التطرق اليه على الاطلاق في وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه ودائما يقولون بانهم قاموا
باستهداف ما يصفونه بالمخ والمسلحين داخل
قطاع غزه يعني حتى على
مستوى التعامل مع قتل زميلنا يوم امس سامر
ابو دقه لم يتعامل الاعلام الاسرائيلي مع
هذا القتل على الاطلاق لم يذكر في وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه وبالتالي هذا لا يمكن
القول فقط بانها حاله ارباك في في وسط
الجنود او بين الجنود في داخل الميدان في
داخل قطاع غزه وانما من الواضح انه تعمد
باستهداف اي شخص في هذه المناطق وتعمد
القتل من اجل القتل لا اكثر ولا اقل وهذا
فقط يؤكده هذا التحقيق الاولي للجيش
الاسرائيلي الذي يحاول من جهه تبرير تصرف
الجنود في الميدان ويقول بانهم استدرجوا
في السابق بنفس الطريقه عندما كتب على احد
جدران المباني باللغه العبريه ايضا هات
سيلو اي انقذونا من اجل استدراج هذه
القوات لكن مره اخرى هناك عده مرات اعلن
فيها الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي عن روايات
واتضح لاحقا بانها غير دقيقه وغير صحيحه
هذا بالاضافه الى التعتيم على امور كثيره
اخرى على سبيل المثال منذ اكثر من 48 ساعه
لم يتم تحديث اي معطيات تتعلق بمصابي
الجنود داخل غزه وفق القوائم التي ينشرها
ايضا المتحدث العسكري الاسرائيلي رغم انه
واعلن فقط يوم امس عن اصابه اربعه من
جنوده وضباطه نقلوا الى المستشفيات وهذا
اليوم راينا ايضا ايه مروحيه عسكريه تقل
احد المصابين الجنود من غزه هبطت في
بالقرب من مستشفى شعريه سادك في القدس لكن
مع ذلك يبقي الاعداد على حالها في القوائم
التي ينشرها المتحدث العسكري الاسرائيلي
وبالتالي حاله التعتيم ايضا والروايات
التي يسوقها الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي في
داخل غزه لها اهدافها لها وهي تخدم بطبيعه
الحال الروايه الاسرائيليه من جهه والحرب
الاعلاميه والنفسيه التي يخوضها الجانب
الاسرائيلي ايضا على المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وعلى الفلسطينيين بشكل عام مريم